eight to go to college at the college of
new jersey it's kind of the eldest born
and somebody that his family really
invested in which later became Princeton
and it was that was an unusual choice
because it was not William Mary which is
where most parents at that time sent
their kids who were in this social class
it was a it was not an Anglican College
so he it was a Presbyterian one and
there was a whole that carried a lot
with it that choice and his father
brought him back after graduating from
college to be a tutor to his youngest
siblings here and he didn't want to do
that but it was sort of the the cost of
being the eldest son the bearer of all
this privilege was that he came back and
was kind of you know forced by his
father to apply all that learning and
investment right back here in Orange
County when he thought it would be much
more exciting to be in Philadelphia kind
of you know being in the cities of the
country and he ultimately made it back
there but Orange County is where you
really understand who he was and how he
came to be if one of the battles of his
life was what was he gonna be and what
was he gonna do for a living basically
what he was really good at was
legislating and understanding problems
researching them coming up with a
solution and an approach to really
crucial public policy problems that
everybody else couldn't understand or
couldn't figure out how to translate and
some kind of solution in politics that
was what he was good at but he because
of the example his father because he
inherited a plantation he had to run he
had a very difficult time ever settling
on a vocation that was outside of
government and public service he had a
terrible time becoming a lawyer he a lot
of the book I chronicled the
difficulties he had being a successful
plantation operator and farmer he had
equally harder time becoming a lawyer
which was what he felt like he needed to
do and there are these really
funny passages where he is complaining
about just how boring and difficult and
intense the study of law is at that time
he never really managed to do it in the
right way he only got an honorary degree
in the law and he would sit here in this
house in the library just battling it
out with these law books and miserable
in the process and very vocally
miserable about it so he he it was a
constant struggle how he was gonna make
a living outside of what his passion was
he had a fit of depression of anxious
depression when he came back he had
these psychological challenges which I
think in the you know I argue in the
book and I do a lot of research that he
had a category of anxiety disorder that
caused him to have these fits and these
these attacks where he would basically
collapse and be out of out of out of out
of commission for a couple days so he's
back here after college tutoring and he
a couple of causes kind of took him over
one of them was the harassment that
baptists were experiencing at this time
in Virginia there
Baptists were a sect of kind of they you
know at this time you needed a license
to preach and they didn't do that and
they're just north of here on a county
called Culpepper their city called
Culpepper they were they were imprisoned
and harassed by the ruling you know
state religion and he was very taken
with that cause of religious
independence religious toleration what
it meant to kind of cast your lot with
an underdog and he there are some
accounts that he traveled up there and
saw what was happening but he took this
on as a cause that was one I think the
political each to use public policy to
express a conviction and a principle and
actually engage and
the questions of governance and public
service really really hit him and he
talked about it that way
pretty soon afterward he became a member
from Orange County to the Constitutional
Convention that did the first this is
after the after the Declaration of
Independence they needed to come up with
a constitution so he was involved in
that he became a counselor to the
governor Governor Patrick Henry as a
very young man it was in his mid-20s so
he he achieved a position in the in the
official post-revolutionary governor of
Virginia when he was when he was in his
mid-20s and that was when he started his
career his conviction on on issues ran
the gamut of to basically every public
policy issue that the country was
dealing with especially at this very
young age when he was a young aide to
Governor Patrick Henry he was he became
absolutely obsessed with the problem of
military supplies so this was a very
difficult question at this time because
the the state was figuring out how to
supply a federal a sort of part federal
part State Armed Forces that was
fighting Great Britain in the
Revolutionary War which dragged on
forever and ever one of the problems was
how do you equip and supply the troops
when the the dollars that they're using
are the there were like five different
kinds of money at this time and they're
all incredibly inflated so it was
difficult to find the food and the drink
and the supplies that the troops needed
and you needed people in government
actually trying to work that problem and
he carried that through to when he went
to Congress for instance when he came
back to Virginia as a as a delegate
after having been in Congress he got
fascinated by the problem of overhauling
Virginia's state codes that it didn't
have all these medieval punishments in
it like capital punishment for all kinds
of random things or the fact there
wasn't a lieutenant governor so he he
kind of threw himself into overhauling
the Virginia law for instance those are
much less sexy and famous examples than
what he did that became very famous like
religious independence the freedom of
religion separation of powers in the
design
bicameral legislature the design of the
presidency he was instrumental in
shaping the federal judiciary it
independently appointed you know very
statesman like federal judiciary so you
know they were there do all those issues
were what he really contributed to in
the design of the country but there were
dozens of others that he also mastered
and and led on one of the grains of the
book the thing that planted the seed for
what became the book Worth was this
discovery I made when I was looking
through the minutes of the ratifying
convention that happened in Richmond and
1788 so was the year after the
Constituent mention in Philadelphia all
the states held conventions to ratify
the Constitution and Madison and his
former boss and this major figure in
Virginia politics Patrick Henry who had
been the governor they faced off against
each other for three weeks Madison was
the leader of the anti-federalists Henry
was trying to tear down the Constitution
in Madison during that time that to
anxiety attacks they were called
epilepsy attacks that caused him to be
removed he had to take himself out and
go say in his boarding house for days at
a time suffering and he described it as
suffering and I think it was because he
experienced as incredibly daunting and
difficult this the pressure of having
the whole country on his shoulders on
his narrow little five-foot-four
shoulders I think that most of the time
when he engaged and in real intense
public battle about something it was not
easy for him because he was an introvert
he was it wasn't it didn't come
naturally to be the leader of a nation
or people I think his leadership came
from the necessity and the gifts that he
had and his understanding that he needed
to solve things through government and
politics and public service and public
policies in the way you did that was by
having to do what you did so was it was
a necessity and he mastered it by dint
of will and this unlikely charisma that
he had and the relationships and the
warmth and his passion and his
conviction but it was always it was
more tortured overcoming of obstacles
for him than it was for somebody who was
you know that who had a Grace and an
ease about being in public or you know I
mean George Washington be the classic
example of somebody who was very at ease
being a leader of a nation or of a
people and there was a charisma in that
that wasn't what Madison's experience
was like at all and sometimes it got you
know crippled him he's like the least
likely person to get involved in
politics they could possibly have
thought of there was a wonderful friend
warm friend of his named Elizabeth tryst
who ran the boardinghouse he was sat in
Philadelphia and there's this one time
when Thomas Jefferson said he should
come back he should run for governor of
Virginia he's the guy and she said it's
a great idea but he could never handle
the she said she called it the torrent
of abuses that he would experience in
public life he was too sensitive and so
the fact that somebody like that whose
closest friends said politics is the
last thing he should do the fact they
did it anyway because of how deeply he
felt the need to address these problems
and have somebody like even if it was
him he's like well it's got to be it's
got to be somebody I might as well do it
it was his conviction that powered and
through and that I think drew so many
other people to him because they knew
that he was the annuity was talking
about that he cared what he was talking
about and that he had figured out an
answer that was probably better than
what a lot of the rest of them had done
and that he was throwing himself into
the ring to figure out the solution for
it the presidency came out of the the
kind of chain of succession and the
relationships that he had and the fact
that he had been secretary of state when
he shifted into the executive when he
became the president of the United
States the deficiencies that he had were
more on display so it was harder for him
to give confidence to the nation during
the War of 1812 and he was criticized
for that and that was one of the things
you saw as even with his staffing
decisions with the cabinet members that
he had the ones involved in prosecuting
the war the signals and the the
image that he presented to the word to
the country we didn't really meet the
moment and that's one of the reasons
that he I think that his image suffered
over the over the decades he very much
met the moment when the country needed
to design its foundation and when it
needed to craft the compromises and the
structure that we're gonna link the
states all together to a much stronger
federal government that we're going to
create the different that the whole
machine that was gonna guide the country
and that's how he talked about his life
when you know one of the initial pieces
of research was looking at the many
different drafts of memoirs that he did
as he got older and older he kept on
refining this very short autobiography
it was like 20 pages and he always
focused almost all of his retrospective
of his whole life on the events that
happened up until he was 37 and he would
pay barely any attention to when he was
president or Secretary of State and I
think it was because he saw his life's
work and his contribution to the world
as having been writing and enacting the
Constitution and not so much you know
conducting the wars it's you know the
country is its chief executive there's a
scene in the Constitutional Convention
in the 1820s when Madison is in in his
old age when he appears and he's been
president Secretary of State and father
of Constitution and he and he takes on
some very unpopular difficult causes
then like giving African Americans the
right of representation and the design
of in the counting of population for
districts and and the scene of people
kind of quieting and hushing and drawing
round him so they can hear what he's
saying
it totally different from you know like
Daniel Webster standing up in front of
people and being blown away by this
powerful oratory but it was that
quietness in the and the the element of
being of being magnetically pulled
toward the depth of what he was saying
that conviction and the fact that he
knew what he was talking about that I
think explains why people were so drawn
to him I do not think that history is
given the right credit James Madison I
wrote the book basically about
statesmanship or you see it in the way
they talked about the federal judiciary
you see it the way he talks about the
United States Senate in the way that he
talks about regular citizens there is
supposed to be challenging in public
opinion they're supposed to be research
and knowledge they're supposed to be
alliances and compromises and debate and
deliberation all of which go toward
pushing to a higher plane and not just
going to the lowest common denominator
and not just playing to what makes
people feel good because we would not be
here but for his statesmanship and any
number of crucial junctures that we had
whether it was freedom of religion or
getting a constitution itself passed we
needed somebody doing what he did and
the fact that we don't think about it
much today I think is the problem
book TV is on the grounds of the
University of Virginia to feature their
library conservation program conservator
Eliza Gilligan is going to give us a
history of the program and showcase some
of their current projects we're in the
book conservation lab for the University
of Virginia library and here we work on
rare books and paper from the Special
Collections library we take take books
apart clean them up and put them back
together the University Library has an
amazing collection of cultural heritage
in the form of books paper photographs
daguerreotype maps letters drawings
audio-visual materials and they are
regularly used by researchers either
student researchers researchers who come
from another part of the country to work
on a book a research project and we
always make them available in the
reading room and so we have to have all
of our collections ready for research at
any given time given the care and the
handling that that can sometimes inflict
damage they needed a conservation staff
to keep books in working order so this
is one of the current projects in the
book conservation lab it is a Salter
from 1475 and it is bound in between two
enormous pine boards and it was brought
in to the conservation lab because this
board had become detached from the text
block and I needed to reattach it
because this book is used quite
frequently in regular semester classes
and also at a summer research institute
here at UVA library the pine boards used
to be a single piece and over the
centuries have split they've been
stabilized by an object's conservator
and then my job was to reattach the
board and ultimately reattach
this loose piece here you can see where
the piece used to belong because the
nail holes are here you can see where
the rust around on the that stain the
parchment matches up with the rusty iron
nail so you know where it needs to go
back on the board
you can also see this sort of swirly
pattern here is the old animal adhesive
that the previous binder used to stick
the parchment in place and then once all
the treatment is done to the interior of
the book the last step will be to place
the original leather spine back on the
book the spine was still and sits you
when I first started working on the book
but in order to have have access to the
spine to inste to apply these leather
pardon me these parchments lips I needed
to peel off the original spine and set
it aside
sort of like working under the hood
popping the hood working on the the
moveable parts of the book and then I'll
put the spine back on and I think once
you do
it'll actually fit pretty well and cover
up a lot of the work a lot of the traces
of the work I did so that it will be
much more visually unobtrusive and you
realize this I will reattach with wheat
starch paste wheat starch paste is a
very flexible adhesive that ages well
and it's a cooked adhesive and we use it
in conservation because you can apply it
in a variety of thicknesses and you
start with a powder a very very pure
wheat powder and then you cook it with
water and you get a very thick blob sort
of Wiggles and then depending on the
type of repair you're doing you strain
it add water and make it very very thin
if you're going to do amend on a piece
of paper using Japanese tissue but if
you're going to do some work with
leather you would thin it to maybe the
consistency of heavy cream maybe a
little thicker and then you would apply
it to the leather and let it soak into
the leather and apply another layer and
then adhere it to the original spine
conservation process starts with a
curator or a librarian a member of the
staff who in the course of their work
sees that a book is in poor condition
they may know that it's going to be
needed for a class the next semester so
they'll contact me and say that
give me some parameters about what the
book is what the letter is how it's used
at the library and then I start to do an
assessment of the item I'll assess the
structure the materials the level of
damage or degradation and then I work
with the curator who's responsible for
that collection area
to say this is the work that I think
needs to happen what is your input in
terms of the historical context the
significance of the structure or the
materials that I may not know about and
then together we work on a treatment
plan to make sure that the collection
item can then go back to the library and
be used safely this is a thomas
jefferson letter that he wrote in
response to a constituent I guess I
can't remember I think he was president
at the time the letter was passed on to
I believe descendant in the family and
those family members tried to keep the
letter together over the years and use
different kinds of tape to put the
letter back together as it fell apart
from handling and being folded and being
opened and folded opened and folded and
so there are different campaigns of tape
here and here and then these orange e
spots were also tape and when the letter
came to us it was framed and had clearly
been on display for many many years and
so there was a lot of light damage that
was also causing problems advancing the
staining of the residual adhesive from
the tape and also making the paper very
brittle now you need to remove adhesive
and paper that's causing damage and the
difficulty in this case was that the
paper had degraded so much from the tape
from being on display that working with
it even as you're removing the tape even
as you're bathing it to take out the
acidic degradation products in the paper
and in those stains the paper starts to
fall apart and break and so after it's
washed and dried you have to spend a lot
of time putting all these pieces back to
together and using your before treatment
documentation to make sure that you've
got everything oriented correctly and
making sure that all the folds and all
the lines match up the way they're
supposed to
I used slow application of solvents by
making a poultice of with Fuller's earth
and you make this little mound that
looks kind of like an anthill and you
surround the area with the residual
adhesive with the Fuller's earth and
then you get another sort of putty of
Fuller's earth that you've dampened with
a solvent and then you put the the putty
in the middle and that will slowly draw
the adhesive out of the paper and into
the the putty and so the the paper looks
or the letter looks really strange
because you've got all these little
mounds that look like little grey ant
hills all over it
and then you wait a few hours for it to
dry and you sort of carefully brush it
away and this this stain goes from being
translucent to being opaque which means
it's made progress this letter has still
but still went through a lot so it's
it's never going to look as perfect as
the day that Thomas Jefferson signed it
but it's not going to look any worse you
start with the level of damage the level
of degradation the strength of the
materials that you have to work with and
then you talked with the curator or with
the instruction and outreach librarian
and you say how is this item going to be
used is it going to be handled in the
classroom or is it just going to be put
on an exhibit and not touched that much
or is it just going to be digitized and
then put away because it's very
light-sensitive or very fragile for
example we have a very large collection
of glass plate negatives those are very
delicate items so we've chosen to scan
them so that they're available
digitally and then the originals are
wrapped in safe packaging and stored
away in very strictly controlled climate
storage so this is a letter from Thomas
Hornsby to Thomas Jefferson and it's in
really poor condition and the iron gall
ink that the author used to write the
letter has corroded in a spectacular
fashion so that pieces of paper are
dropping out and they're dropping out
where the letters in the sentences have
literally eaten through the paper now
iron gall ink is is naturally corrosive
people back in the day used actual wasp
galls that are when a wasp lays an egg
they fly up to a tree they put their
little abdomen up against the tree
stabbed through the the bark of the tree
lay the egg in the tree the tree says
hey wait a minute this is not tree and
starts to push it out and that's how you
get this lump that's called a gall
somehow people came up with the idea of
cutting these off of trees chopping them
up and using them to initiate a chemical
reaction as long as you mix it with gum
arabic iron filings and some water to
make this ink the ink naturally corrodes
it starts out sort of yellowy and clear
and then turns dark brown as the air
mixes to dry it but in the case of this
letter there's really unusual corrosion
in the form of this sort of yellowish
opaque maybe crystal may be something
else that's risen to the surface of the
paper and we're not really sure what's
going on and so we're trying to find a
corrosion expert to work with to help us
come up with a responsible treatment
proposal traditional iron
or standard iron gall ink corrosion we
can put it in a chemical bath that will
stabilize the iron gall ink but unless
you're absolutely sure that that's what
you have going on you don't want to just
put something in a chemical bath
so we're do some more research and see
if we can come up with a way to at least
stabilize the letter if we can't
actually do a chemical treatment that
would remove the corrosion you know you
don't make an attempt every time you
have to be honest about your skills
honest about your knowledge and also
aware that conservation research is
ongoing with regard to paper inks all
kinds of materials and you may not have
the knowledge now but that doesn't mean
that someone won't figure out the issue
later on so if you can't in good
conscience make something better off by
physical intervention you you have to be
very honest with the collection managers
with the librarians and say I can't I
can do this much right now and we'll put
it in a box
we'll make a digital image and then put
it away for safekeeping the training is
incredibly challenging you have to do
our history training or take classes you
have to take chemistry general chemistry
organic chemistry you have to have
natural talent with regard to hand
skills you have to be really patient you
have to be very thoughtful you can have
certain skills with art but if you don't
have the patience if you don't have the
commitment to doing research and
thoughtfulness it's it's not going to
work I work in book and paper but there
are conservators who work in plastics
there are conservators who work in AV
material they're conservators who work
on film and our whole goal is to make
our cultural heritage available to
whomever is interested
today on book TV it's the fifth annual
San Antonio book festival beginning at
1:30 p.m. Eastern
our programming schedule includes author
discussions with Carl Jacobi and his
book the strange career of William Ellis
the Texas slave who became a Mexican
millionaire at 2:15 p.m. Eastern jeff
Guin with his book the road to Jonestown
Jim Jones and the People's Temple at
3:00 p.m.
Lydia reader with her book dustbowl
girls the inspiring story of the team
that barnstormed its way to basketball
glory at 3:45 tim hernandez author of
all they will call you then at 4:30 p.m.
Eastern author allene irani with his
book there goes the neighborhood how
communities overcome prejudice and meet
the challenge of American immigration at
5:15 p.m. Eastern Alexandre Zapruder
author of 26 seconds a personal history
of the Zapruder film and at 6:00 p.m.
Lydia pine with her book seven skeletons
the evolution of the world's most famous
human fossils watch the fifth annual San
Antonio Book Festival today at 1:30 p.m.
Eastern on c-span two's book TV
here's a look at some books being
published this week Massachusetts
senator Elizabeth Warren talks about her
blue-collar childhood and discusses her
efforts in gaining support for the
middle class on Capitol Hill in this
fight is our fight Pulitzer
prize-winning historian David McCullough
shares a collection of his most
patriotic speeches in the American
spirit former New York Mayor Michael
Bloomberg and former Sierra Club Chair
Carl Pope explore solutions to climate
change and climate of hope Jonathan
Allen and Amy Parnes examine the
missteps of Hillary Clinton's 2016
presidential campaign in shattered also
being published this week former
Washington DC public defender James
Forman discusses how 1970s criminal
justice policies supported by
african-american leaders have impacted
the criminal justice system in locking
up our own David gran of The New Yorker
takes a critical look at the FBI's
investigation of the murder of dozens of
members of the Osage Indian nation in
Oklahoma in killers of the flower moon
and poet Lisa Peterson shares her
experiences as a Rikers Island GED
teacher in all-day look for these titles
in bookstores this coming week and watch
for many of the authors in the near
future on book TV on c-span 2 and now on
book TV we've got a full day of events
from the San Antonio Book Festival this
annual Book Festival was held last
weekend we kick off the day with Carl
Jacobi he tells the story of William
Ellis who later became known as
Guillermo le Co the slave turned Wall
Street Book Festival and to c-span's
book TV my name is Michael Soto and I'm
an English professor at Trinity
University here in San Antonio San
Antonio is soon to celebrate its tri
centennial so we've been taking stock of
our history in a serious way lately and
that's just one reason why Karl Jacobi's
exciting new book the strange career of
William Ellis the Texas slave who became
a Mexican millionaire is so important
Carl Jacobi studied at Brown and Yale
and is now a professor of history at
Columbia
University in New York where he lives
with his wife and son his work which
includes two previous books developed
small carefully crafted tales to address
some of the largest issues in American
history
from the role of the environment in
shaping human power relations to the
challenges representing the profound
violence experienced by North America's
indigenous peoples in strange career of
William Ellis Jacobi brings to life the
story of an elusive figure known
variously as wh Ellis Guillermo Ellis
and Guillermo and Atika le sail the book
strips away the layers of mysteries
surrounding Ellis le sail revealing a
long ignored history of slavery and
emancipation of racial mixing and racial
segregation in the us-mexico border
lands the result is a study that casts
into sharp relief the intimate and
tangling across national boundaries that
have rendered Mexico and the United
States inseparable elements of a shared
North American history so please join me
in welcoming Carl Jacobi good morning
everyone
what Michael and I thought we'd do is
that I would give a very brief overview
about the book and I wanted to read a
short excerpt for you then we're gonna
have a very short conversation up here
and then we wanted to get some questions
from the audience I hope that sounds
okay with everyone good and for me I'm a
historian I as Michael mentioned I teach
at Columbia University and it's a real
pleasure for me to get outside the
classroom and to be at a book festival
like this one particularly because I'm
think about history as literature that I
think it really can be told in a very
creative sort of way and I think about
the book that I wrote here although it's
is technically as a history I like to
think about it as a nonfiction novel I
think that what historians are forced to
do is that we're supposed to tell a true
story and I really think that we need to
think about both of those terms we need
to think about what makes it true and we
also need to think about the story
aspects of history the narrative as
that really have an appeal and can draw
people in to the the lessons that we're
trying to impart from the past in terms
of my book the subtitle in many respects
gives away the plot of the book it's
called the Texas slave who became a
Mexican millionaire and it's about
someone named William Henry Ellis who
was born in a small Texas town not too
far from here Victoria Texas which some
of you may know and then he eventually
he moves to San Antonio he actually has
an office here on military Plaza in San
Antonio but along the way and then he
moves on to New York City and along the
way he ends up changing himself from
William Henry Ellis to this character
known as Guillermo and Rica Eliseo who
everyone thinks of as an incredibly
wealthy Mexican from Mexico City in New
York City he lives on Central Park West
which if you know New York City is one
of the sort of main most prestigious
avenues they're overlooking Central Park
as a name would imply he has an office
on Wall Street and it's right next to JP
Morgan who is the preeminent investment
banker of that particular time period so
he's really in the seat of power during
that time period he is I like to think
about him as a real-life Great Gatsby
he's this person from the sort of small
town anywhere USA who comes to New York
and reinvents himself and so you can
think about it he is a self-made man
he's a self-made man in two senses he's
a self-made man in the sense that he
went from rags he's born into slavery
and he eventually is able to be become
quite wealthy and live in the sort of
most prestigious addresses in New York
City
he's also self-made and that he
recreates the image of himself during
this time from someone who was seen as
african-american to someone who is then
seen by most as a Mexican and so this is
in many respects a story about about
passing about about you know racial
masquerade and this was actually a
standard element of most novels of the
Harlem Renaissance as Michael who's an
expert
the Harlem Renaissance could tell you so
that all lots of novels everything from
Nellie Larsen's passing which is about
the issue of passing or James Weldon
Johnson 's novel the autobiography of an
ex-colored man this is a very common
theme in in a lot of fiction from the
early 20th century and it initially it
was curious to me I was wondering why is
it that historians because there's very
few histories almost no histories about
about racial passing and I thought why
is it that there are no histories about
this when when fiction writers are
talking about it so much and then of
course I tried to research it and I
realized well now I know why the paradox
about doing a history like this is that
you're trying to write the life story of
someone who's trying to hide his life
story so it's not like you know George
Washington where you collect all his
papers and there's a big library and you
can just go and find everything this
really was a treasure hunt or a
detective story in terms of finding out
all of the background about him and this
is why I think that it's much more
common that people have dealt with the
issue of passing and novels because of
course as a novelist you can invent all
the details and fill all of the the sort
of missing pieces in using your
imagination and of course as a historian
I'm not allowed to do that and it took
me as a result about 10 years to write
this book because I had to do so much
searching around to find these tiny
scraps of evidence and to put them
together into the story that I'm sharing
with you one of the key parts in terms
of making the book reality for me was
tracking down some of William Alice's
family members and I eventually was able
to do this both family members who were
from Victoria and moved to San Antonio
and then as part of the great migration
actually moved west to Los Angeles
and then other parts of his family which
had gone down and
moved to Mexico and one of the the
ending part of the book actually the the
final coda to the book is that these two
branches of the family have lost touch
with one another it's a very common
story actually that the border ends up
dividing families and families can get
out of touch and whoa when I I finally
contacted them I was able to put the two
halves of the family back together so
the code of the book is basically a
transporter a transnational family
reunion where these two parts of the
family that had been out of touch for
some 75 years come back and get to be
reacquainted with one another
what I wanted to do was just to read you
an excerpt from the opening of the book
and just to set the scene for you a
little bit this scene would take place
in 1909 and it takes place on a luxury
train a luxury Pullman train that's
going from Mexico City to New York City
these two great metropolis of North
America during this time period and the
moment that the the opening talks about
is what happens when you cross the
border from Mexico into Texas and this
was a very key moment on the train
because in the whole question emerged
was what race are the passengers because
Mexico had no Jim Crow it had no
segregation Texas of course in 1909 had
segregation and virtually all aspects of
life to try to keep the so called race
is separate from one another and so one
of the questions that comes up is they
would have to reshuffle the passengers
when they cross the border and so that
means that the border then as now is
this question where where issues about
identity are really become extremely
salient in everyday life because you
have to figure out who is this person
and where am I going to categorize them
because of just this process of just
traveling a few feet from one side of
the border to the other a few other
details just to make the excerpt makes
sense so this is the the Train cut
through the the border at address
negatives and which on the other side
would be the town of Eagle Pass Texas
and the train itself is called the Aztec
limited this
sort of like I said a deluxe train that
came from Mexico City so I think with
that should be enough to get you through
this and let me read a short excerpt for
you for the passengers aboard the Aztec
limited crossing the border at was at
once routine yet momentous after the
train journey to cross the bridge
spanning the Rio Grande and pulled into
the one-story Depot on the eastern edge
of Eagle Pass agents of the recently
created US Department of Commerce and
labor dressed in the regulation dark
blue uniforms with brass buttons climbed
aboard to inspect the passengers and
their luggage agents events no interest
in narcotics like heroin marijuana or
cocaine all legal in 1909 but sought
instead imported delicacies in an era of
high tariffs and no federal income tax
the federal government raised the bulk
of its revenue through duties on
luxuries such as lace silk jewels
watches and cigars next in a measure
that spoke volumes as to the may
brokeback sorry
next in a measure that spoke volumes as
to the Border's role in establishing
personal identity as well as national
territory
these same agents compiled a report of
inspection on all incoming passengers
detailing each arrivals name place of
birth occupation and final destination
the United States would not require
passports until 1914 so rather than
focusing on reading ones documents this
procedure hinged and said on reading as
it were once person determining the
truth of an individual's stated identity
through language dress physical traits
and other clues on ordinary passenger
trains agents exercised particular
vigilance against Chinese or Japanese
laborers who in an effort to evade the
United States restrictions on Asians
often disguise themselves as Mexicans as
well as immigrants considered iron arcus
poppers are the possessors of loathsome
or dangerous diseases but on a luxury
train like the Aztec limited catering to
well-to-do businessmen and upper-class
tourists agents more often than not took
individual's declarations of identity at
face value
on the morning of March 14th 1909
however a tall man with penetrating
brown eyes and carefully groomed
moustache attired in the latest fashion
spats top hat tailored three-piece suit
gold watch-chain
and jeweled fob draped across a powerful
barrel chest caught the eyes of
authorities in Eagle Pass like the
others on the Aztec limited the pastor
had begun his journey from Mexico City
in a first-class pullman once he crossed
the border into the United States
however a new question arose what race
was he for despite his elegant
appearance his skin had a somewhat
swarthy tone and unlike Mexico the Texas
of 1909 possessed segregation laws
designed to limit contact between blacks
and whites in everything from schools
restaurants libraries graveyards and
hotels to railroad cars when asked the
newcomer insisted he was a Mexican
entrepreneur on his way back to his
office on Wall Street after negotiating
the purchase of several rubber
plantations in his homeland his name he
offered was Guillermo and Vijay at a
sale which for those who might have
trouble with foreign pronunciations
could be translated into English as
William Henry Ellis moreover as an
ethnic Mexican he was legally white and
not subject to Texas's segregation law
statutes at least a few on the train
however had caught wind of vague half
whispered rumors circulating along the
border that for all his obvious wealth
and sophistication
Eliseo might not be the well-to-do
Mexican he claimed to be could it be
that his olive complexion was a product
not of a Hispanic background but rather
of a covert african-american one
dismissing such assertions le sale
refused the conductor's attempts to
relocate him to the negro coach after
the aztec limited reached US soil only
once a train crew summoned the local
sheriff charged with enforcing Texas's
segregation statutes did Ellie sail
grudgingly obliged but not before
bowring to all within earshot that he
would spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars if necessary to sue the railroad
for the humiliation of forcing him to
ride in the Jim Crow car who was
Guillermo Enrique Eliseo such was the
question
many found themselves asking if the turn
of the last century as his dapper yet
enigmatic figure flitted in and out of
an astonishing array of the era's most
noteworthy events scandalous trials
unexpected disappearances diplomatic
controversies most linked in one way or
another to Latin America uncertainties
about his ethnicity do not confine
themselves to his 1909 border crossing
and ego pass during his years in the
public eye commentators preferred
proffered a kaleidoscope of
possibilities the New York world
observed that Eliseo has a looks and
dash of a Spaniard and speaks several
languages
Denver's Evening Post asserted that le
sail was a wealthy Mexican in fact
without doubt the wealthiest resident of
the city of Mexico others maintained
that he was of Hawaiian blood or a Cuban
gentleman of high degree editors at the
San the Kansas City Star whoever
cautioned that the stories of his
Hawaiian ancestry are not to be credited
while an equally suspicious
correspondent to the Baltimore Sun
discounted the rumors that Elysee was of
Cuban Brazilian Mexican and who knows
what other Latin American extraction
concluded the New York Sun just where
Elie sale came from no one hereabouts
seems to know
[Applause]
thank you for um you mentioned a moment
ago that you've been tracking down the
story of William Ellis for the past ten
years or so but I understand that he's
been on your mind for much longer than
that can you tell us how you first came
across this figure sure so I was I don't
even know I don't even want to count the
number of years now but way back when I
was in gret way back when I was in
graduate school I was looking at some
records on from us consoles in in
northern Mexico this was something one
of my professors it advised me to do and
all of a sudden what I discovered there
was this event that happened in 1895
which was hundreds of african-american
sharecroppers from Alabama and Georgia
were relocating to northern Mexico to
Sen de along the border between Durango
and Walla and I thought this is very
interesting whenever we talk about
immigration between the u.s. and Mexico
we always talking about Mexicans coming
to the United States we don't ever think
about why would Americans go to Mexico
although of course if you're thinking
about eight the 1890s so this is one one
year before Plessy vs. Ferguson the
separate-but-equal ruling by the Supreme
Court and just the presence of Jim Crow
there's lots of reasons why
african-americans would actually find
Mexico a potentially attractive place to
be and so I got very interested in
thinking about this sort of hidden other
migration that we don't think about and
I got very interested in once I was
looking through the records at trying to
figure out who was behind this who did
who would realize that with the new
train system between the u.s. and Mexico
that it didn't necessarily only need to
go from north to south that actually
could go from south to north and it was
a very mysterious figure who went by
these various names of William Ellis or
Giamatti sale and that's the initial
spark that got me interested in trying
to figure out who was this person who
had this very interesting vision of the
border and what the relationship between
the US and Mexico could be
today we're located downtown at the main
branch of the San Antonio Public Library
not far from where Ellis lived and
worked since you spent so much time
immersing yourself in 19th and early
20th century San Antonio life as you
research the book I'd like you to take
us back there for a moment what was this
place like then that's a great question
you know it's in really one thing that's
really fascinating is that San Antonio
was his hub of trade across the border
into into Mexico connected particularly
to Monterrey and so I don't think it's
at all accidental that William Ellis
ends up moving here there's a couple
things that are that are happening so he
grows up in Victoria you can't pass as
it were in your hometown right I mean
everyone knows you they know your family
and so you need to go someplace new
where you're unknown and the closest big
city to Victoria is San Antonio and
there's a train that's created built in
the 1880s it allows you to relocate to
to San Antonio and once you're here
there's a large there's a fair that's
about one-third ethnic Mexicans tejanos
at that time period and so there's
really a large community that he can
blend into and no one knows who he is
and so but it's not accidental it's not
only the closest big town it's also the
town that's most connected with Mexico
and so throughout his life William Ellis
is always at these places that are very
much on the frontier between and
relationships between the US and Mexico
he's born in Victoria which is really
where the southern plantation belt ends
and the northern Mexican sort of cattle
ranching frontier begins in those two
places really overlap in a very small
portion of Texas really the heart of it
being Victoria here in San Antonio he's
at the heart of where there's
transporter trade so he was in military
Plaza and all of those buildings around
military Plaza would have been traders
who are involved with Mexico and a lot
of those buildings would have been their
storehouses where they're storing things
like cotton
and cattle hides and everything else for
the trade back and forth across Mexico
and as I think most people know also
military plazas in some ways where the
that's a sort of seed of where San
Antonio's great food comes from because
every every evening they would actually
come out and have Mexican food and sell
that there in military Plaza and then
later in his life when William Ellis
moves to New York that may seem like an
odd thing to do but New York is Wall
Street is completely fascinated with
Mexico during this time period that
almost everything that's happening in
the United States economy is one way or
another connected to Mexico so this is
the early 1900's as a period of
electrification so you need copper and
where does copper come from comes from
Mexico it's the creation of the
automobile and where does rubber or oil
for the automobile come from it comes
from Mexico even things that you have
the rise of junk food as it were and so
chocolate and vanilla and Chi clay for
chewing gum where does this come from it
comes from Mexico and so by being in New
York City he's also he's once again at
the the place where the relationship
between Mexico and the United States as
at its most articulated format
the slave narratives are quite obviously
foundational to the african-american
literary tradition and the theme of
racial passing as you mentioned a moment
ago plays a central role in the
emergence of what we now call
african-american literature including
fiction and nonfiction about characters
who pass not as white but as Latino you
mentioned in the book Langston Hughes
and you just mentioned James Weldon
Johnson and I and you also mentioned
nella Larsen who we might also think
about the work of Jessie Redmond Fawcett
who depicted this effort to pass as lot
you know in fiction is there any
evidence that Ellis was at all familiar
with the literature of slavery or tales
of passing that's a great question
that's a fascinating question I I have
to believe he was although at the same
time the the trickiest part about the
book is he's living in New York City
during the Harlem Renaissance right and
I feel that on some level he's
participating in that even though he has
to be very careful about how much he
gets involved in it because he's trying
to hide certain aspects of his
background but it's that that's one of
those sort of fascinating unprovable
things one of the themes I talk about in
the book is the notion of him as a
trickster which I think comes from
African American folklore and I do
believe I have to believe that these
tricks are stories which were really
central to folklore from slavery and its
aftermath in some ways I think informed
his perspective on the world but that is
a sort of leap of faith that I'm making
and trying to contextualize his cultural
background as I read your book he struck
me as someone who could easily be a
character in the work of say James
Weldon Johnson
and because he deploys some of the
strategies that Johnson himself in his
own autobiography confesses to deploying
when he would occasionally pass his Cuba
mm-hmm what were Ellis's strategies for
for passing you you touched on some of
them but I where if you could spell this
out a little bit more yeah it's it's
fascinating that's a great question
because it I think we think about
passing is purely about phenotype and
and there's a little bit of that of
course and that he's he's relatively
light skinned and so that allows him to
say that he would be Mexican and if you
can look at the cover the photo he also
sort of cultivates one of these big
Mexican style mustaches but there's a
there's a lot more to just your visit
than your physical appearance that's
involved so part of it is of course
dress and the way that he dresses
invokes a very upper-class form of
mexicana dad that's very much sort of in
touch with European models that are very
influential in Mexico at this time
period and language is a big part of it
as well so that there's a great line
from Langston Hughes that I quote in the
book and James Weldon Johnson does the
same thing so that when you have to go
buy your ticket on the railroad and the
railroads are one of the places that are
segregated during this time period you
buy your ticket in Spanish and the
ticket taker will often make the
assumption because there's really no way
to prove what your race is you know at
this time has a driver's license or
passport or anything so the ticket taker
will make an assumption of this person
who talked to me in Spanish they must be
Mexican and they will sell you a ticket
for the first class the first class car
and so language can become a really
useful tool and James Weldon Johnson
does the same thing where he's speaking
Spanish on the train and and that they
don't throw him out of the first-class
car because they think he's Cuban and so
it's this is one of the things I think
he first William Ellis first learn
Spanish because he was picking cotton
alongside Mexican field hands and
Victoria and that interesting early
interaction then allows him to do
all of these other things and really in
an interesting way play on the
stereotypes of of white Texans who have
a certain sense of what a Mexican is
supposed to be in what an
african-american is supposed to be and
he's able to manipulate those
stereotypes to his own advantage I'm
gonna ask one more question right now
but then we'll invite questions from the
audience if you do have a question we
ask that you use the microphones so that
the TV audience can hear what you're
asking as well so you you mentioned a
moment ago that you analyze the the
photograph of Ellis in much the same way
that a ticket seller would read is his
character what were some of the other
tools of evidence that you deploy in the
book to get at this very tricky and
elusive story yeah that's a great
question to the the in many respects
this book I think would have been
impossible without the digitization of
the archive that we've encountered and
I'm not one of those people who
uniformly loves this sort of embrace of
the web and we must digitize everything
but the tricky thing as I was saying
about William Ellis is that because he's
a I'm trying to write the story about
someone who's trying to hide his life
story is that there isn't one obvious
place where there's a lot of sources
about him and so that I use but there
are things that we have now so that a
lot of census data has been digitized a
lot of newspapers have been digitized so
you can put in his names and his various
pseudonyms and you can actually get all
sorts of stories about him popping up
all over the country and all sorts of
unexpected places and eventually using
those those digitized census records I
was able to track down family members
and that was really important for me
because it allowed me to match up what
his see what his public persona was this
is what the newspapers are giving you in
some ways what the sort of public image
is and then once you could hear what the
the families had you could get a sense
of what his actual family background was
like and they had lots of great photos
including the
photo that's on the cover of him in this
this top hat and a lot of and some
personal letters and a lot of great
stories and it was an interesting
combination of bringing together the
family stories the family history and
then this much more public record of
what he was imagined to be and seeing
the the gap that existed and how he
navigated between this gap of what his
background was and then his sort of very
elevated image in public life during
this time period well do we have any
questions from the audience please join
us at the microphone
you did mention that you started the
book ten years ago and you've been
thinking about it since graduate school
so since it's been published have you
learned more about the subject have
people come forward and giving you more
information you wish you had for the
book so far not too much although
generally that's that's one of the
things that's fascinating that that that
does shake loose whenever you write a
book in this case one of the things I
did as I created a website about the
project first and so a lot of the people
who I did want to contact particularly
the family in Mexico which is incredibly
hard to track down
they were I was able to track them down
before the book came out which was
really transformative for the book and
it enabled me to do that family reunion
the I don't know if there's exactly an
answer to request from one of the things
that I'm really looking forward to is
next month in Mexico right outside of
Mexico City
William Ellis's great-granddaughter is
getting married and I'm invited to the
wedding and then as as well are some of
the family members from the US side of
the family